So welcome to our very first homework assignment.
This is number 1. [Homework Assignment #1]
Just to recap, in the class we learned about localization. [Localization]
We learned about about histogram filters. [Histogram filters]
And we programmed some in Python. [Python]
So the homework assignment will cover this plus some very basic probability. [Probability]
[Question 1] In the first question, I'm going to ask you some very basic probability questions.
We have random variable X and the probability of 0.2.
What's the probability of the complement?
We have 2 random variables, X and Y, whose probability individually is 0.2.
And X and Y are independent. [X, Y independent]
What's the probability of the joint X, Y?
And we have the variable P(X) with probability of 0.2,
and we have 2 conditionals, P(Y|X) and P(Y|¬X), both 0.6.
What's the probability of Y?
Here you have to apply total probability.